today I'll show wash not that flash ah
the flash runs real fast on TV Grant
Gustin man we're talking about the CW's
flash and today we're gonna talk about
the season premiere of season 3
flashpoint right now on fat man on
Batman hello welcome to another
fun-filled episode of fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith I'm not Menard this is a
delight flash is back folks now I've got
a reason to live I hated when it went
off the air for the summer but now it's
returned I just got back from directing
an episode of the flash episode 7 of
season 3 so I have the benefit of having
seen not only episode 1 which airs this
week on the CW check local listings mmm
but I've seen up til I've seen one two
three and four I know what five is about
and I know what six is about and I've
made seven so I saw seven but in tiny
pieces over the course of a couple weeks
you got to live you got to live flash
again before the rest of us did because
you were up in it your balls deep in
flat I was balls I'm not gonna say that
cuz I want to keep going back and I
think that would creep them out though
like don't let that guy up here oh it
was there they're doing [ __ ] cool
things with this season man it's not
like originally when we saw the tail in
the last season we're like that don't
flash point and we've since heard that
it's not a whole season of flash
protection but and what we've we've all
seen yes the season premiere by this
point well they will have yeah this is
actually up before I think we're going
up like a minute before it hits I think
this was a Tuesday all right that goes
up when we shouldn't spoil too much [ __ ]
except for Oliver ball we're spoil is
all spoilers man so if you're watching
this only in it it's gonna get spoiled
so you might want to wait until the
episode airs come on back but if you
can't believe it
we're gonna [ __ ] tell you some [ __ ]
what happens in Episode one it's called
flash point yes all [ __ ] episodes
entitled flashpoint and the events of
episode 1 set in motion the events
the rest of the season so with episode 1
we pick off not directly where we left
off from the end of season 2 if you
don't recall was buried deciding to go
back in time and stop the reverse-flash
from killing his mother he just lost his
father right they put zoom away and he
was hanging out with iris iris [ __ ]
kissed him and she was like I'm ready
for this and [ __ ]
so everything was looking kind of good
accepted Barry as petulant heroes due to
sounds then he would not be happy living
with the girl of his dreams
yeah in a world without his both of his
parents yeah and decides to monkey with
the space-time continuum which as we all
know will end great because it does all
the time for anybody who ever does that
I would point out though it did end
great on one occasion remember the first
time he [ __ ] blasted through that's
the time barrier and wound up in a world
where Cisco had been killed by dr. wells
with the [ __ ] hand in the chest the
vibe Rohan and [ __ ] like that
and then all of a sudden Barry reset the
timeline by accident and Cisco wasn't
dead mm-hmm so something to think about
not that it me not that it plays
anything into the plot or anything a
season but something to think about when
everyone starts you know being like hey
what's going on around here sometimes
[ __ ] with the timestream is good
Cisco was alive because Barry
accidentally [ __ ] with the timestream
this though wasn't intentional [ __ ] of
the timestream because he didn't realize
that everything would change as
drastically as there was a reason why
Starfleet has an entire division devoted
to temporal Guardians right yeah because
probably Kirk [ __ ] with the timeline
so often and probably annihilated entire
civilizations that they felt it was time
to police this I love that I love the
idea of [ __ ] time storylines I know
like you know [ __ ] good because I'm
gonna get a lot of them what is it
timeless is the one thing no tomorrow is
NCW which i think is another time when
legends of tomorrow is literally like
we're [ __ ] with time flash this
season is all about [ __ ] time and
then there was an
Oh [ __ ] they're doing a remake of time
after time that's right with Genesis
from tusk and yoga which is in Genesis
Rodriguez but it's a remake of that
amazing [ __ ] loom Malcolm McDowell
Mary Steenburgen should the David Warner
does the Jack the Ripper so time is a
big deal like for this millennial
generation I guess right like who's
Millennials don't make the decisions
who's making the decisions well glory
people our age who grew up on Terminator
and Superman and back to the future also
their middle age they see less time
ahead of them than between them behind
them yeah right is that the expression
more time behind min ahead so they're
sitting there gone if I could go back I
want any money you went for like Harvey
we lose no that's share [ __ ] mag dad
feel so confident right now that's
Ronnie what's [ __ ] weirder as I knew
that it was cher you did like Bonnie
Tyler that's a total eclipse of the
heart in my world that's a you know
symbol of masculinity absent knowing
when the eighties cher hits dropped okay
so we're talking about flesh speaking of
turn back time mmm Barry goes back the
end of season to turn back time and the
last thing we saw was him very emotional
beat stopping the reverse-flash from
from killing his McQuillen his mom this
is the last time you'll ever killed yeah
you're never gonna kill her again and he
stops him from doing it and you know his
mom is all terrified and he's like it's
okay you're safe now and that's how they
ended it because you're sitting there
going oh my god he did if he doesn't if
he saves his mother does even become the
flash anymore above them huh
so now we're seeing what happens and
essentially it takes place three months
down the line little me yeah and you get
those those little nods and people
saying like it
it's only been three months but I can't
have only been three months cuz I feel
like I've had an entire life yes and
Barry has had the life he's never had
before he gets to be with both of his
parents something he hasn't had since
he was a boy who actually want him to
move out yes really funny man like he's
[ __ ] gone to Helmand back keep his
parents alive and if I could bring them
together again the neighbors have a room
for like [ __ ] off do you want me to
leave but we're not ready to go and he's
charmed by the hope it really is
expensive we want to [ __ ] each other out
loudly [ __ ] and I'd worry about our
year-old son looking at our house he's
like I don't want to run Barry run he
he's got that what doesn't he have he's
got his job yeah but Joe doesn't like
him yes
Irish doesn't know him yes if you look
familiar we've been to school together
in every threes you never met Cisco not
as that is one of my favorite aspects of
this episode first off I'll just throw
that out there in front street I think
it's one of their best episodes of the
flash easily at the top [ __ ] five if
not three and up there for me is like
the season finale of season one this is
an amazing piece of [ __ ] television I
thought this it's not saying it stands
shoulder-to-shoulder with that episode I
thought it was insanely strong entry
yeah into flashes especially like they
again like they're you know we're all
thought oh my god it's gonna be a season
of flashpoint
and they've told us that that's not the
case so this episode was kind of like
well how they're gonna handle all these
things then these did expectations that
I have based on the top and they do a
really nice job of doing it and then
using that as the kind of jumping-off
point for their whole season um I'm
trying to think how much what more can
we say well we can just we're beretti
spoiling it yeah I mean like he doesn't
know he doesn't know Caitlin in this
world yeah Joe
juh bummer he's got a super chilly
relationship with Joe West he finally
asks iris out on a date that's very
sweet their meet-cute is one of my
favorite things I've ever seen in the
show his like practicing to talk to her
and bump into her instead
and Candace just [ __ ] crushes it she
has gotten just better and better each
season and they're giving her more [ __ ]
to do instead that that was a wonderful
note to play cause we've seen her and
Barry together since the beginning yeah
so it was kind of like almost like
getting to see an Origin and they were
so [ __ ] adorable together but then it
you know [ __ ] as things do in flesh
world things start falling apart because
he can't give it up like he was like he
wanted this life he wanted his parents
he wanted the chance to just like no
superheroism no nothing just I want to
be a guy with parents who I love but he
still has his powers that he's not
willing to give up but and the fact that
he can't give up his powers is what
leads him to realize that he can't stay
there like the more he uses a speed the
more he loses his memories of the world
he left behind and he wants those
memories and Kid Flash mmm exists in
this world so we get to see Wally in the
suit yeah right off the bat first
episode and it's [ __ ] fantastic and
Barry gets to watch and not be a part of
it the other fun we get is eobard thawne
returns and it's not Tom Cavanagh it's
the other guy who's great and he kind of
has the who's the villain now Barry
moment where Barry essentially you know
at the end of the episode you like
wasn't gonna do he captured him I guess
and put him locked him up where he
brings him [ __ ] big belly burgers
every day and you know he sits there and
[ __ ] and he's in a cage the glass
cage that can't he's not affected by the
timestream right he's what he indicates
is that still remembers but it's also
he's not able to use his power so
there's his memories aren't going away
right so he's like soon we'll be the
only two left who remember right the
other world and it's such a weird like
like again like the whole season is
predicated on he makes a decision that
he made at the end of the last season
and then he goes back and try to fix it
and figures out oh my god I can't but he
did that in season one but it wasn't a
bad thing
Cisco went from being dead to being
alive but in this version of the world
that's created by his flashpoint
activity there's everything is just off
and in some cases tragically so where as
is the case with Cisco but and I think
at the tail end of this episode like the
third or fourth act out is again
spoilers huge [ __ ] spoilers there's
another speedster called a rival that he
and Kid Flash are trying to fight and
Wally gets speared by a spear thing and
it is going to die and then that becomes
Barry sort of impetus like okay I can't
let this happen either but you know and
with his memory slipping away like he
starts to realized that this is actually
not the best of all possible worlds I
left it behind when I did this mm-hmm so
and the heartbreaking choices every
episode of the flash apparently has to
have for Barry he's got to choose to let
his mother die again no no that's it's a
real [ __ ] kick in the ass when he has
to go back to your bar Thawne he's like
all right
there you go go back because you're
saying it - he's a year to be begging me
to kill your mother
you know you piece of [ __ ] and then it
on the end of the episode like these
right yeah yeah there's a it's
essentially this whole season feels like
it's gonna be butterfly effect mm-hmm
the idea of that one [ __ ] selfish
decision made by a guy to be fair is
always putting himself out for others
are you really is like everyone's always
honest a dick about you folk did go
Barry but it's like he saves everybody
and she's always helping best and in a
moment of weakness he's like [ __ ] man I
just wish my mom was here
so you know you can understand where it
comes from and it's just it's like Tony
Stark syndrome right like he creates all
his [ __ ] own enemies and [ __ ] like
yeah Barry could sometimes be his own
worst enemy but he tries to correct it
and that's where the that's where our
whole [ __ ] season comes from when I
had my the natural order of things this
is what you get I am having seen deeper
in and know and not only just haven't
seen but having read than having heard
and knowing what's to come is a [ __ ]
dynamite see
I know we're only talking about episode
1 and 21 episodes from now you're gonna
see something [ __ ] mind-bending where
you're gonna be like how the [ __ ] did
they do it again
how the [ __ ] did they pull this out
their asses it is phenomenal where the
season [ __ ] goes so I thought the
opener was insanely strong and that and
I saw that like [ __ ] weeks ago long
before I got to see anything else or
read anything else I think I even
watched that before I got to read my
episode mmm so it's it was a completely
[ __ ] satisfying viewing for me as
like you know the way everyone watched
it or will watch it tomorrow night
whenever this goes up that was the way I
watched it like but at the office you
know and I watched it not as a gonna
filmmaker going well I'm directing the
next episode so let me take this in I
watched it go on like oh this is good Oh
like it was just [ __ ] fantastic
and then I guess so I know where it goes
in the next I know where it goes for the
next floor but the next episode if that
episode is called flashpoint which it is
the next episode is called paradox
that's probably out by this point um but
yeah my god his [ __ ] dope what do you
think yeah I mean I know the one thing
that I didn't like about it and it's not
even there was execution based or and/or
performance based or anything it was
that I wanted to live in that world a
little bit longer like I wanted to I
wanted to see the other ramifications of
what flashpoint did to everybody else
now that we live in a connected universe
right like but when you say ramification
we're a morphic Asian is what we're
gonna see all season long right what you
wanted to see was a little more like oh
my god let's spend time here how did his
decision affect arrow
how does Supergirl and les mark that's
the problem is like in order to you know
they're making their show the flash I
mean if you start going like hey let's
check in on Ali like that's
they got Stephen Amell on their show
like it just becomes a matter of
scheduling they got Stephen Amell on
their show on arrow every [ __ ] day
they can't spare him for a day to go
over to flash or for a [ __ ] week to
go to flash to play like the dark alley
they did it once last season and becomes
like a big deal
across her memory was an alleged our
colleague so it becomes a more s'more of
a scheduling nightmare like it seems
like they're saving their [ __ ] right
like they've got sober killers for their
big crossover which is coming up but I
hear what you're saying like it'd be
dope if they did but you just realized
it's a logistical nightmare to do it's
like going I wish Ben Affleck was on
this season like yeah we all wish that
but it's like it's just not possible but
if the version that I want is less a
crossover between the three and I would
like an episode of arrow to be that
other version but you know so in our our
yeah in arrow not a flush I don't
everything's over see that's the danger
and that's why I think they might have
said like you know you got to imagine
the writers room for flash for season 3
flash right how much can we do like that
oh my god the toy box is open we could
do alternate characters of all this all
these different people and stuff like
that but if you write like nothing Jenna
so here I connected universe starts to
suffer because you're like how come it
ain't effect an arrow why is it
affecting legends of tomorrow and now
that Supergirl is join CW it's like
where is the effect on Supergirl so it's
probably just like look rather than open
up that can of worms we're into this one
episode self-contained and then Barry's
gonna reset the universe and most of the
ramifications happen in flash world
right yeah I totally get the logistical
I just there's a part of me that would
love to see and I get them you can't
like start every episode of these shows
with a flashpoint tie-in even though
that would be the comic book version of
it well there's a world in which like it
[ __ ] shoot me 10 minutes of what it's
like in each of those universes and put
on the DVD there's oh my god like just
all you got to do is I'd like to use it
like did you see superhero Fight Club
yeah so they did last season they did
this thing superhero Fight Club without
their characters like in a [ __ ]
Danger Room type scenario fighting they
did a new one that includes Supergirl
it's so [ __ ] fun and stuff maybe
something like that well yeah it would
have been cool like I just want to see
who arrow is in that is it Oliver Queen
or is it Oliver Queen's dead well
there's a reference isn't there at one
point
solutely there's a Queen reference I
forget what it was
but yeah like here's the thing and you
know I'm now not to apologize for these
[ __ ] they know what they're doing
this shows [ __ ] dynamite but the
crossovers that are about to happen
which I was episode 307 flash flashes
episode of the crossovers 308 so the
very next episode shooting had a scene
with like [ __ ] I think was thirteen
or fourteen of their characters in
costume in one room well I was just like
can I go I just want to be in that room
just so like what [ __ ] [ __ ]
Instagram but so they're delivering big
time particularly the storyline that
they're doing for the crossover which I
know I'm gonna favorite now [ __ ] so I
[ __ ] say no you want to go back but
it's it's [ __ ] dope and for an
old-school DC fan it's like and I'm not
talking way old school I'm just talking
Connor bold school I'm not talking
crisis old school no not that far back
but it goes back to a DC miniseries
crossover event that I loved when I was
collecting and they're doing it for the
crossover I was like oh they're doing
the Lord's work over there on those
Berlanti shows I don't just say that
because I just got back from the flash
and I'll head up to Supergirl in a
couple weeks like I like these [ __ ]
shows and like I'm happy to watch him
one of the first things I did when I got
the flash this time was like how many
episodes done already and they're like
we just wrapped five we're heading into
six six was shooting while seven was
prepping so as I can I see as many of
the finished episodes as possible and
they were like yeah if you want I was
like [ __ ] it that's why I'm here I feel
like we thought you were here direct I
was like everyone always thinks American
early I'm just there so yeah man they
kick off the season in a big bed
wonderful way and yeah I guess like yeah
it might be nice feel like this give us
five episodes of flashpoint yeah but
they're gonna make up for it by giving
us I've seen what's on the plate that's
the thing I can't I got a little I got
too much inside info so I know what's
coming so I'm like [ __ ] that dude you
should see yes oh yes yes do you wait
this is like they got a hit show on
their hands and each season they up the
ante in the storytelling they're like
alright let's do this let's do this and
this year's story arc is fantastic and
the epic
Toad's that they're talking that I've
read about that they've told me that
they're doing that aren't necessarily
deeply tied into their mythology are all
so [ __ ] dope and they've got
throwaway moments that are coming up in
episodes that'll just make you go like
because you realize they've now built a
[ __ ] connected universe enough to
just have somebody pop up for a scene or
something oh that's [ __ ] cool
I'm willing to wait for it flash season
three is off to a running good start
[ __ ] the Speed Force is with it
so now how was it how was your second
flash experience tougher yeah yeah like
I'm not tougher like the people suck
well fire all the good people you know
is like oh my god I was working with
[ __ ] no they were all [ __ ]
wonderful people what I realized was
last time I dragged never saw the flash
the runaway Dinah stirrups the exact
stance for a wonderful episode but not a
lot of action not a lot of heroics
either so he shows up in the suit at the
very end and he has one kind of like
chases down [ __ ] girded and lo fight
with him generally speaking there's just
people talking to each other and stuff
and even though he was talking the
speedforce they were in real places so
not a lot of special effects pretty much
just shooting people talking to each
other so we motored the first three days
I got us out at noon each day we were
just gonna [ __ ] it fast so at lunch each
- and say going back on this day one it
became apparent my second episode of
flash like oh I realize now that I had
it easy
last time cuz this script for my episode
7 is much more like a flash episode in
as much as there's a lot of him in the
suit running around there's a lot of
[ __ ] super-powered effects there's a
lot of stunts and [ __ ] like that and
there's fantastic things like I was so
blessed to get this episode a lot of big
major firsts in my episodes so I'm like
ah but there was a lot a lot more work
this time I'm not more work where I'm
like I'm leaves you don't like working
but I mean we were there we went used up
every hour of our day we went late on
some nights just to get the volume of
material we needed to get which was also
[ __ ] you know very action-oriented
much more than last time so if I was I'm
so happy with what we shot I think the
show looks fantastic I think like you
know now that I'm through it I'm like
whoo I'm glad I did it but in the middle
of it I'm like oh I missed the [ __ ]
script where there was nothing happening
and people just said things to each
other he's talking donkey more I like
window boy bit his brother it was it was
just like you know in here here's what I
at the end you know you kind of look
back on everything and again it's not
like all [ __ ] the people were
wonderful that that part of the
experience was the same if not better
because this time around we all knew
each other and stuff but like I'm glad I
did this second episode of flash before
I went to do Supergirl if I had gone
from my first episode of flash -
Supergirl because the way I understand
it
Supergirl has a lot of effects every
minute of every [ __ ] day because
she's Supergirl
so he did the boy just runs real fast in
the flash a girl and Supergirl like you
know she's like achoo you know and
everything she does is a [ __ ] flying
effect shot stuff so there's a lot more
effects work in the Supergirl episode
whatever it's gonna be that I'm gonna
direct then there was in my first flash
episode so doing a second flash episode
that had a lot more effects work in it I
think might have saved my ass for
Supergirl because it was honestly it
would have been gone from like zero to
120 based on like how much effects work
gets done on the Supergirl show so now
I'm prepared like I probably would have
[ __ ] broke in the first three days of
Supergirl wouldn't it like what how good
we're going to take it so long why did
you have to fly something that's not
like John Peters like she shouldn't fly
is hard now watched your episode of
Supergirl is like she's in a kryptonite
prism and it's just talking talking from
please please I love being a part of
that world it's [ __ ] great I can't
wait to go back hopefully I get to go
back next season I think every episode
is booked for this season at this point
so maybe I get to go back next season
but in two weeks I get to go up to
Supergirl so hopefully well I hope
that's one more like you know like I'm a
little scared I'll be honest with you
I'm okay
about going to Supergirl no anybody
really over there Tyler did the you know
the production design on flash he's over
on Supergirl stuff but it's not like you
don't hang out with that dude he's
[ __ ] designing the production so so
it's once again going into an unfamiliar
place and like you know you run the risk
of being exposed as a [ __ ] charlatan
or fraud they're like think you're a
director you know [ __ ] like that so it
worked out on flash so much so they want
when I went to go back it was like ah it
was like honestly dude it doesn't feel
like a job it feels like baseball
fantasy camp
like where you show up at a thing or
hockey fantasy camp you show up at a
thing and you're surrounded by [ __ ]
pros and legends that you love and
they're like all right we're playing
hockey now you're important here we go
it's on your stick put it in the baby
they set me up dude it's like when I go
to flash I'm like [ __ ] I'm like I'm
like date I'm like [ __ ] this give me
a hockey reference Dave some cement I
was gonna say yari curry of it like but
he's a great player in and of itself
like
Gretzky just needed it another body
there helped if he had a skilled hockey
player but if you were just the other
guy he could [ __ ] pop it off your
stick into the [ __ ] net he could use
you but make you look like you did the
thing like they say that like his his
game if you were played on his line as
long as you did what you're supposed to
everyone he elevated he brought people
for a journey with them same kind of
thing here when I show up there then
that cast and crew they make that
episode they're just very sweet about
being like hey look at him he's in
charge you know the big boy it's like
whenever a kid comes to set and I'm like
you get to direct this shot like really
a mogera
you sit right here you say actually you
said god it's all on you and stuff it's
the exact same scenario for an adult and
so you know I appreciate it I love going
up there cuz I'm like oh my god this is
amazing I wish I could do this every day
but it's fantasy camp you only could do
it once in a while otherwise you know if
I can you might not see it for as
beautiful as it is so I go I'm a little
scared about going to Supergirl just
because it's like oh my god brand new
people but I did that on flash hopefully
blood positive results on Supergirl if
not I won't go back to National City
well I want to go back I like playing in
these sand boxes dude it's nice to be
able to jump into a world and be like oh
yeah we run run run fight fight and then
by everybody and [ __ ] off and they gotta
[ __ ] worry about it for the rest of
season you're doing other [ __ ] we're
gonna do we're come in gonna play for a
while cotton candy rollercoasters gon
feel like yeah and then you leave and if
you never overstay your welcome you know
what I'm sayin if I was there every week
they'd be like [ __ ] fat-ass who
didn't do the matrix is here again but
now instead like you pop in you're like
we're having a good time and then you
[ __ ] off until next year it's happy time
keV again everybody
I sweat a little cab goes a long way
that's what they say ah so there it is
man not only if I can a review of the
season opener of flash season 3 flash
points that's a little inside [ __ ]
dope mmm the directing process and [ __ ]
like that
good times man on the set of the flash
ah so there it is thanks for tuning in
man [ __ ] we're gonna be back next
episode talk about more things probably
not flash related but we'll be checking
in on flash every week believe me now
that might as well call this show fat
man on flash man because yeah now the
show's back I'm gonna do it we'll be
running to catch up and Supergirl I
[ __ ] love this show so much
I turned my kid onto the show she loves
the [ __ ] show a lot and now it's nice
having a thing you could share with the
kid you know what I'm sayin like flash
is the first show I didn't talk about it
before the first show that I've never
watched with my son where I am NOT like
sacrificing for him and he is not
pretending from me you know they're
making me well we're being random it's
the same exact line listen dumbass kid
show I gotta wind or it's not something
he's got a ponderously
looks great and mutant as a parent the
amount of sometimes you got to watch it
you really don't want to watch do things
you don't want to do when you can find
something you're like oh I like this I
like this together you like this we like
this do this awesome oh my god that's
gold yeah and when he hasn't theories
about
it's much like you know dad I'm pretty
sure that Barry likes iris but he's
never told her
really okay buddy because he's coming to
this like the first sugars ever really
cared about so all of these tropes that
we all know just turn them be like
course he does man this is a television
fake things happen on telling stories
it's good that's nice the bad [ __ ] you
go watch this with your kid honestly you
can watch the blue cage of the kid too
you can if you're prepared to have some
discussions about I mean there was
definitely he likes coffee we know that
but there wasn't like a lot of I mean
there's a lot of violence in terms of
lying there they're obviously some
people [ __ ] died they probably have
more deaths in Luke Cage than they had
in daredevil season one I think so and
you're also like anytime he just
concussed us somebody accidentally like
who knows what happens after that I
wanna see the spin-off of the [ __ ]
people who's like he literally flicked
me I'm in a wheelchair I go Luke eight
hopefully infer what I don't feel bad
for because they're all [ __ ] who
shouldn't have been involved in bad
things but at the same time it forces
you to like deal with like do I feel for
them as a human or a prisoner like could
be compelling yeah like now I'll just
stick to think what happens well here's
what Luke Cage knocked out the support
pillars of my house whose busting
through a wall being all badass saving
one nurse out of the thing 15 people
died because glad the nurse is fine good
for her but [ __ ] I lost my
grandfather
I loved grandpa is rascal just couldn't
get over the rubble
those things are slow who cages fast
he's I mean he's got he moves like
you've got a purpose and he just knocked
down all the support structure so you
see I'm carrying a woman while I was
going on he's [ __ ] loose my
grandfather had died I admire those Luke
there was a door right next to that wall
you just brush them through the door the
door Luke and all so many [ __ ] he
fights his way out of prison
I just punches through the walls and
then later on like braceros like you
swam that far is liked it look is long
right now anyway that's Luke Cage Luke
Cage flash what a golden era man which
means that it flashes on Supergirl is
about to be on air O'Hara is about to
return for those that watch arrow and
legends is returning as well week of
awesome Oh
oh what a great time to be alive Lord
don't kill me yet so many great shows
too much to do too much to watch that's
it for fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I'm mark barnard tune in next time
same fat time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
a man's meat Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder